[Music]
now he mm-hmm absolutely can I do Lauren
so today I'm going to be listening to
different European accents and judging
which one's the sexiest I'm most excited
to just get male attention I was in
Europe second to fifth grade and I took
French the entire time I was there
completely lost it I can get by in
Spanish I went to Greece once I know two
words I took Spanish as my minor in
college completely lost that so like I
know foreign languages do I speak them
no not at all
you ready for the first is he ready
let's throw a question
bring them on bring them all mr. Greece
hi hi are you I'm good how are you
Oh tell me more capacity are sort of
lemma I don't know what you're saying
yes I will I will okay okay I'll tell ya
okay till today family so much clinica
like people coughing us muffled tipota
right okay would it what I tell I see
almost post a post on Marcela nunca was
powerful map or a formality pata did I
didn't totally oh god I wish I knew what
you were saying
push when Linda stopped you sir
uh-huh so okay if it doesn't matter
poor like yourself that much just you
know pistol Wow
the whispers really just mm where's my
cd4 loves still some date it's a day
that's what you say hey look at that
lovely the khatallah way next no no no
no absolutely unacceptable
why would you do this oh hi yes now I
married my mom he just let him off mr.
France
[Music]
what's our what's our whatever hello
what's up oh come on - yeah yeah yeah -
flaccidity imagine they say like a lady
family the first kid is not even on
Sadie Mae
major posture before yeah um oh good I
don't know what you're saying but I'm
down for you imagine company can we can
we can we can we can't really do I'm
free
wait wait okay super sit down sit down
see fair mahalia just completely fell
apart emoji the dispute uh-huh we get
sweet I'm gonna keep the food cause I
forget about it important can see if you
don't want to keep the house give the
phone say say say foo you can again
directly Mulligan listen could do Mona a
kid enemy the buter quiet quiet oh hey
ma ma boys you must have something
wait wait hi all right Polly married
sorry
mr. Spang
hold on all that Catan it okay state
oven see see see ya know honesty
misshapen poco de españa poco okay
Hadassah I don't know what you're saying
there Oh what that means okay
still we're gonna understand a given T
there's some fellow here so he he loved
that game well stairs tell me and this
time will be any boy where's McCord
August RFK that cake on me you're not
pooping in your custom stanton mad Stan
I don't know live let's see oh your dad
II wanna push a game in contrast and the
motherís tomorrow if so so fun
apprenticed under Molineux it is all of
a given gun Daria
oh wow nice yeah sounds great let's do
it it sounds like you wanna you just I
don't know it sounds naughty though you
know that II wanna go check on me and
Ariana Senna Unnithan a from Antigua
Cydia on this path yet
see I don't bite uh so nothing I don't
want to get on the SEC for demos I'm
party at football ooh oh yeah football
football are spine
hasta que puedes la vida que esté sabado
tengo que bueno gay monomeric arrest
paulo mañana en casa y tenía pensado
Orsola famous impersonal service you
want to take me to your place on
Saturday that sounds great
you want my number I
hello oh you're not married are you Wow
Wow
taking a Spain I'm gonna have to go with
mr. Greece I literally had to come out
of my clothes listening to the man speak
to me I don't know what he said but it
was beautiful sweet nothings I would say
probably France I don't even know why I
just was totally enraptured by mr.
France and I've never been to France so
it could be a nice opportunity I learned
you can have everything you want okay I
don't pick one actually I changed my
mind I want all of them
[Music]